but in the creative process you actually
have to get outside of time in order for
you to be able to create the familiar
past is the known the predictable future
is the known present moment is the
unknown that is where all possibilities
exist so there's a function of
three-dimensional reality in technology
where more things are happening in a
shorter amount of time certainly there's
some type of energetic thing that's
taking place to me that energy is
actually endorsing whoever you want to
be so if you want to be a victim get
ready because it's going to get really
good for you because that energy is more
available if you want to heal wow
there's a lot of people healing now and
they're using that energy instrumentally
in a positive way so we have the data to
show that when you're relaxed and awake
amazing things can actually happen to
you instead of in survival stressed out
and in a program so in order to create
something new we got to be we got to be
in the present moment